Grazie
Buonasera
Allora
La seconda guerra di indipendenza
Non sto a ripetere le cose che abbiamo detto ieri
Su come lo spazio delle guerre
Come dire
È condizionato in modo decisivo
Dal territorio su cui si combattono
Non sto a ridirlo
Tanto peggio per chi come persona di Freddi
Non c'era ieri sera
Non lo saprà mai
La seconda guerra di indipendenza
Lo sappiamo tutti
È la riedizione della prima
Con una grossa differenza
È una riedizione della prima
Nella prima ci abbiamo provato
Nel 48 si è detto
Forse si riesce a buttare fuori gli austriaci
Dal Lombardo Veneto
Le forze
Non del regno di Sardegna da solo
Figuriamoci
Ma in quel momento sembrava di tutta Italia
Ci stavano tutti
Il Papa, il Re di Napoli, il Gran Duca di Toscana
Magari bastano le nostre forze italiane
Per buttare fuori l'impero dal nord
E invece non sono bastate
Nel 59 ci si riprova con una grossissima differenza
Che negli ultimi anni
Cavour ha tramato in tutti i modi possibili
Per fare in modo che questa guerra
Stavolta si rifaccia con altre condizioni
Altre condizioni vuol dire
Non andiamo da soli
Non va più il regno di Sardegna
Praticamente da solo
Ma con un poderoso alleato
Con la massima potenza europea
Almeno continentale
La Francia di Napoleone III
La cosa riesce
In altre parole
Cavour riesce a convincere Napoleone III
Che pure come politicante
Ne sapeva quasi quanto lui
Che tutto sommato
È nell'interesse della Francia
E dell'impero aiutare gli italiani
Dare questa botta all'impero d'Austria
Ridimensionarlo
Dunque Napoleone III ci sta
Nel gennaio del 1859
Viene firmato un trattato di alleanza
Tra il regno di Sardegna
E l'impero francese
Che in pratica equivale
Alla guerra contro l'Austria
Alla prima provocazione
La Francia si impegna a entrare in guerra
Immediatamente il Piemonte
Comincia a richiamare riservisti
A richiamare i soldati in congedo
Per mettere l'esercito sul piede di guerra
Immediatamente l'Austria
Comincia a richiamare riservisti
E a mandare nuove truppe in Lombardia
È la classica escalation
Una volta che le cose si sono innescate
Vanno avanti
Ma naturalmente quando c'è un escalation
Di questo tipo
Succede anche un'altra cosa
Che i governi
Gli altri governi
Si preoccupano
Non è che succede qualche cosa di grave
Che a noi non fa comodo
A noi inglesi
A noi prussiani
E se invece cercassimo
Di mettere pace
C'è una questione italiana
Certo
Nessuno può negarlo
Però molti governi
Preferirebbero
Che questa questione
Si risolvesse
Con un bel congresso
Invitiamo gli austriaci
E discutiamo con loro
Se sono disposti a dare qualcosa
I piemontesi
Non è neanche detto
Che li invitiamo
Anzi
Gli austriaci dicono
Chiaramente
Noi veniamo
Se non invitate i piemontesi
Cavour al congresso
Non lo vogliamo
È un po' pesante
Ma il governo inglese
Ci pensa
E anche il governo francese
Perché Napoleone III
Da un lato
Si è lanciato
Ha firmato l'alleanza
Però al momento buono
Un po' di paura
Si prende
All'idea che sto per fare la guerra
Questa idea
Di fare un congresso
Senza invitare
Il regno di Sardegna
E mettersi d'accordo
Con l'Austria
Per qualche settimana
Circola
E sembra proprio
Che vada a finire
Così
Cavour
Vive le settimane
Più terrificanti
Della sua vita
Perché il congresso
Vorrebbe dire
La catastrofe
Di tutta la sua politica
Cavour
Minaccia
Di dimettersi
E emigrare
In America
L'Italia
Evidentemente
Non è più un paese
Dove si possa fare qualcosa
Minaccia
Napoleone III
Dicendogli
Guarda che se tu mi fai
Questo scherzo
Nel congresso
Io rendo pubbliche
Tutte le trattative segrete
Che abbiamo avuto
Ma Napoleone III
Esita ancora
Ci sono delle lettere
Di Cavour
In questi giorni
In cui Cavour dice
Faccio fatica
A non perdere la testa
Me la tengo ferma
Con le mani
Perché non scappi
Il 19 aprile
Sembra che Napoleone III
Abbia deciso
Si fa il congresso
L'ambasciatore francese
Malewski
A Torino
Va a svegliare Cavour
Per dirgli
Che l'imperatore
Ha deciso
Cavour salta sul letto
E dichiara
Ora non mi resta
Altro da fare
Che spararmi
Un colpo di pistola
E farmi saltare
La testa
Quello stesso
19 aprile
Cavour
Fa testamento
E lascia una lettera
Per il nipote
A Inardo
Cavour
Non si è mai sposato
Non ha avuto figli
L'erede universale
E il nipote
Cavour
Quel 19 aprile
Lascia una lettera
Al nipote
In cui gli dice
Speravo di farti
Ereditare
Un nome illustre
E benedetto
Dagli italiani
Invece
Probabilmente
Il tuo nome
Sarà associato
Alle sciagure
Del nostro paese
Lo stesso giorno
Cavour
Scrive al suo amministratore
Sapete che Cavour
È un grosso uomo d'affari
È l'uomo più ricco del regno
È un grandissimo
Imprenditore agricolo
Scrive al suo fattore
A cui pochi giorni prima
Aveva dato ordine
Di vendere il bestiame
Perché le proprietà di Cavour
Sono nel Piemonte orientale
Vicino al confine
E se si fa la guerra
All'inizio
Non si sa cosa succede
Quindi l'amministratore di Cavour
Ha ordine di vendere il bestiame
A costo di perderci
Ma il 19 aprile
Cavour scrive di nuovo
All'amministratore
Non si dia più
Verun fastidio
Per la pronta vendita
Dei buoi grassi
Già che pare
Che la guerra
Più non si faccia
Salveremo le vacche
Ma perderemo
La causa italiana
Che pareva prossima
A una soluzione favorevole
L'imperatore
Napoleone
È stato ingalinato
O è un traditore
Come vedete
La situazione
È abbastanza drammatica
Dipende solo dall'Austria
Che Cavour
Si spare un colpo in testa
E che la cosa
Sia finita lì
Se l'Austria
Accetta di andare
Al congresso
È finita
Per fortuna
Si può sempre contare
Sul governo austriaco
In questi casi
Il governo austriaco
Decide che il congresso
Non gli basta
Vuole umiliare
Il regno di Sardegna
Fino in fondo
E quindi
Prima di accettare
Il congresso
Gli austriaci
Due giorni dopo
21 aprile
Mandano un ultimatum
A Torino
In cui ordinano
Al governo piemontese
Di licenziare
I richiamati
E rimettere
L'esercito
Sul piede di pace
Altrimenti
Sarà la guerra
Cavour
Riceve questo ultimatum
E si lustra agli occhi
Non riesce a crederci
Ho avuto un'altra
Un'altra colpa di fortuna
Non ci credeva più
Invece sì
E' scritto nero su bianco
Se non licenziate
L'esercito
Sarà la guerra
Cavour
Comunica subito
A Parigi
E a Parigi
Piemontesi
Han tre giorni
Per rispondere
Secondo l'ultimatum
Ma è chiarissimo
Che diranno di no
Già il giorno dopo
A Parigi
La gazzetta ufficiale
Che si chiama
Il Monitor
Annuncia
Che sua maestà
L'imperatore
Ha ordinato
La formazione
Di un nuovo esercito
Che si chiamerà
Armée d'Italie
L'armata d'Italia
Come naturalmente
L'armata
Dello zio
Il grande Napoleone
Ai vecchi gloriosi tempi
Perché Napoleone terzo
Naturalmente
È un nipote
Napoleone terzo
È il nipote
Del vero
Grande Napoleone
Figlio del fratello
Ed è un uomo
Notevolissimo
Napoleone terzo
Poi come dire
La sua memoria
Davanti alla storia
È rimasta un po'
Appannata
Dal fatto che
Undici anni fa
Undici anni dopo
Per gli storici
Si confondono
Un po' sempre presente
Passato
È tutto sempre lì
Undici anni dopo
Napoleone
Ha fatto una guerra
Idiota
Contro la Prussia
È stato sconfitto
A Sedan
Ha dovuto abdicare
È morto in disgrazia
Quindi è passato
Alla storia
Come un imbecille
In realtà
Napoleone terzo
Era un uomo
Di mille risorse
Nel 59
È un vecchio
Avventuriero
Di 50 anni
Che ha passato
La vita
A cospirare
Per cercare
Di diventare
Imperatore
Come suo zio
Ha preparato
Colpi di stato
Società segrete
È andato in esilio
Ne ha fatti
Di tutti i colori
Poi alla fine
C'è riuscito
Nel modo più imprevisto
Chi c'era ieri
Si ricorderà
E anche gli altri
Si ricordano
Che nel 48
I francesi
Fanno la Repubblica
Ma si sa
Che ai francesi
L'idea
Dell'uomo forte
Comunque
Da Napoleone
In poi
Non è mai dispiaciuta
Quindi fanno
La Repubblica
Ma chi
Eleggono
Presidente
Della Repubblica
Il principe
Napoleone
Il quale
Capisce subito
Che quella
È la sua opportunità
Si presenta
Alle elezioni
E viene eletto
Dal popolo
Presidente
Della Repubblica
Ci mette solo
Qualche mese
A preparare
Il colpo di Stato
E proclamare
L'impero
Il colpo di Stato
Fa centinaia
Di morti
In Francia
E migliaia
Di persone
In galera
Però poi
Schiacciata
La resistenza
Delle piazze
Il nuovo
Imperatore
Ripristina
Il suffragio
Universale
Fa un bel
Plebiscito
A suffragio
Universale
E i francesi
Lo eleggono
Imperatore
Dopodiché
Napoleone III
Continua a barcamenarsi
In questo modo
E è
È un classico
Bonapartista
Nascerà una categoria
Politica
Il Bonapartismo
Quello che da un lato
È un dittatore
Però col consenso
Del popolo
Governa con la polizia
Segreta
E con i plebisciti
Controlla i giornali
Però c'è il Parlamento
È tutta una cosa
Difficile da gestire
Bisogna essere bravi
Napoleone galleggia
A lungo
Tra la destra
Clericale
E la sinistra
Rivoluzionaria
Quando decide
Di fare questa guerra
In Italia
Ha fatto una scelta
Di sinistra
La guerra in Italia
Non piace al Papa
Non piace ai clericali
In Francia
La destra
Cattolica
È assolutamente
Ostile
Però piace
Alla sinistra
È una guerra
Di sinistra
Rivoluzionaria
La stampa
Francese
Esalta
L'imperatore
Che sta per ridare
Alla Francia
La gloria
Che le spetta
Escono articoli
Che dicono
Finalmente
Vendichiamo la battaglia
Di Waterloo
Poi a Waterloo
Gli Austrici
Non c'erano
Ma insomma
Non importa
C'erano i prussiani
La gente
In piazza
Canta la marsillese
Che è proibita
Ufficialmente
Però la gente
La canta
E l'imperatore
È contento
Napoleone
Naturalmente
Ha un sogno
C'erano il sogno
Di diventare
Imperatore
E ci è riuscito
Ma non basta
Se sei
Napoleone
Terzo
Devi far vedere
Che vali
Quanto lo zio
E lo zio
Era un grande
Generale
E Napoleone
Terzo
Non ha mai combattuto
Una guerra
In vita sua
E deve far vedere
Che è anche
Un grande
Generale
E che l'esercito
Francese
È di nuovo
Grande
E che la Gloire
È lì
A portata di mano
Perciò
Napoleone
Decide
La guerra
Il 26 aprile
Scade l'ultimatum
A questo punto
L'Austria
Dichiara guerra
E dipenderebbe
Tutto
Dalla velocità
Qui torniamo
Al nostro discorso
Di fondo
Le guerre
Si fanno
Sul territorio
Nello spazio
Dov'è il confine?
Al Ticino
Come nel 48
Cambiato niente
Sul Ticino
Ci sono gli austriaci
Quello che è cambiato
È che i piemontesi
Da soli
Lo sanno
Che perdono
A questo punto
Vengono i francesi
Ma non è che arrivano
In un giorno
I francesi
Se gli austriaci
Fossero ben comandati
All'inizio
Potrebbero fare molto
Se ci fosse ancora
Il vecchio Radetzky
Che 82 anni
Ha vinto
Custosa
E 83 anni
Ha vinto
A Novara
E che aveva combattuto
Già i tempi
Di Napoleone
Quello vero
Ma il vecchio Radetzky
È morto
L'anno scorso
A 92 anni
Adesso al comando
Delle forze austriache
In Lombardia
C'è un altro generale
È un ungherese
Si chiama Giulai
O meglio
Giulai è il modo
In cui lo pronunciano
Gli italiani
L'ungherese
Non pretenderete
Che lo pronunci in ungherese
Ma comunque
Gli italiani
Lo chiamano Giulai
E tutti lo conoscono
Perché il comandante
Austriaco
In Lombardia
È una figura
Conosciuta
Ovviamente
È un nemico
Il nemico
Anche in tempo
Di pace
Giulai lo conoscono
Tutti
Io qui
Ho un ricordo personale
Una parte
Della mia famiglia
La parte di mia madre
È originaria
Del lago Maggiore
E io mi ricordo
Ancora da bambino
Delle zie
Che si ricordavano
Le vecchie canzonette
Che si cantavano
Contro Giulai
Nel 1859
Va da Giulai
Che venga la primavera
E con la primavera
Verranno i francesi
Verrà la guerra
Ecco
Giulai quindi
Deve stare attento
Però all'inizio
Le carte in mano
Le ha lui
L'esercito austriaco
In Lombardia
È forte il doppio
Di quello piemontese
Il triplo
Deve solo
Invadere il Piemonte
Passare il Ticino
Chi c'era ieri
Ricorda
Che problema è
Per questi eserciti
Lenti
Che vanno a piedi
Carriaggi
Cannoni
Vagoni
Cassoni
Un sacco di roba
Tirata da cavalli
Bestia
Ecco
I ponti sono pochi
Passare i fiumi
Non è uno scherzo
Ci vuole un po' di coraggio
Giulai non si muove
Eppure tutti sanno
Che sarebbe fondamentale
Fare in frettissima
La guerra è scoppiata
Solo da tre giorni
E già a Giulai
Arrivano
Gli insulti
Perché non si muove
L'ambasciatore austriaco
A Parigi
Che sta facendo i bagagli
Naturalmente
Perché è scoppiata la guerra
Manda a Vienna
Un telegram
Dicendo
Qui fra tutti
Tutta la nostra ambasciata
Vuol farvi sentire
Il grido di dolore
Di impazienza
E di rabbia
Il grido di dolore
Era di moda
All'epoca come espressione
Ma questi sono gli austriaci
Di rabbia
Per le esitazioni
Del generale
Conte Giulai
Diamine
Non gli resta
Che passare il Ticino
Attaccare i piemontesi
Rovesciarli
Schiacciarli
E se ne sta fermo
Perché piove
Siamo alla fine di aprile
E effettivamente
Diluncia
Ticino
E gonfio
I ponti sono insicuri
Giulai non si muove
Tutto sta di vedere
Se si muoverà
Prima che si muovano i francesi
I francesi si muovono in fretta
E qui si scopre
Cioè noi scopriamo
Che sono passati
Soltanto undici anni
Dalla prima guerra
D'indipendenza
Ma il mondo è cambiato
Perché nel 48
Non c'era il treno
E invece nel 59
C'è il treno
E quell'altra grande novità
Che è la nave a vapore
C'era anche prima
Ma ce ne è molti di più adesso
Mentre Giulai
E fermo sul Ticino
Che guarda il cielo
Per vedere se smette di piovere
Napoleone
Va in treno
A Marsiglia
E lì si imbarca
Su un vapore
Per Genova
Con una parte
Dell'esercito
Un'altra parte
È avviata
In modo più tradizionale
Verso la Val di Sursa
E scende in Piemonte
Da lì
E queste cose
Cambiano il modo
Di fare la guerra
In altri tempi
Prima che i francesi
Arrivassero in soccorso
Passavano mesi
Adesso bastano
Due settimane
Perché tre corpi
Francesi
Sbarchino a Genova
E da lì
In treno
Possono andare
Dove vogliono
E altri due corpi
Scesi dal Moncenisio
Anche lì
Alla fine
Trovano il treno
In pianura
E possono andare
Dove vogliono
15 giorni
Giulai
Se ne è già giocati
I 5 o 6
Finalmente il 30 aprile
Giulai passa il Ticino
Gli austriaci invadono
Il Piemonte
Primo maggio
Sono a Novara
Il 2 passano
La Sesia
Sono a Vercelli
La stampa italiana
La stampa francese
Segue da vicino
Questa marcia
Degli austriaci
In Piemonte
E naturalmente
Escono gli articoli
Che denunciano
Le atrocità
Gli abusi
Le violenze
Di questa invasione
Noi che abbiamo sentito
Parlare di quel che è successo
Nel Novecento
Ci viene da ridere
Perché le atrocità
E gli abusi
Sono che gli austriaci
Sì
Dappertutto
Requisiscono il bestiame
Non per niente
Cavu voleva far vendere i buoi
In ogni città
Dove arrivano
Obbligano il sindaco
Tirare fuori
Soldi
Vino
Pane
Bestiame
Per 10.000 uomini
Per 20.000 uomini
Certo
E' il modo di fare la guerra
Requisiscono tabacco
Requisiscono scarpe
Per i giornali francesi
E' la prova
Della barbarie
Del nemico
A Torino però
Sono un po' preoccupati
Anzi
A dire tutta la verità
A un certo punto
C'è il panico
Il 4 maggio
Cavu scrive
Alla sua amante
Bianca Ronzani
Ballerina
Ungherese
Sposata a un certo Ronzani
Che poi è uscito di scena subito
Che è da circa tre anni
E' la sua amante
A cui Cavur vuole molto bene
L'ha comprato una bellissima villa
4 maggio
Cavur a Bianca
Cara Bianca
Quale felice combinazione
Che tu non sia a Torino
Non so più dove era
Ma insomma
Non è sul posto
Già che le notizie
Sono sempre più cattive
Gli austrieci si avvicinano
E il re
Non si muove
Ci torneremo
Non è certo
Che essi vengano a Torino
Ma è probabile
Siamo decisi
A difenderci
A oltranza
Ho fiducia
Nel coraggio
Dei piemontesi
E nella provvidenza
Ti abbraccio
In quei giorni
Cavur
Va a visitare
Le barricate
Nella periferia di Torino
E le parate
Della guardia nazionale
Tutti i bottegai
Armati di moschetto
Per vedere
Se arrivano gli austriaci
Se si riesce a fare
Un po' di resistenza
Dice Cavur
Il re non si muove
Dov'è il re
Con l'esercito
Non
Fra Torino e Vercelli
Perché l'esercito
È troppo piccolo
Stare lì
A aspettare gli austriaci
Vorrebbe dire
Farsi battere
E basta
L'esercito piemontese
È cambiato anche lui
Rispetto a undici anni prima
Undici anni prima
Era un esercito di riservisti
Il servizio di leva
Era breve
La gente
Che faceva un anno
Il militare
Poi li mandavano a casa
E li richiamavano
In caso di guerra
Nel 48
Si è visto
Che è stato un disastro
Arrivavano tutti questi
Contadini e operai
Che avevano dimenticato tutto
Bisognava reinsegnargli
Come si spara il fucile
Alla prima difficoltà
Si spaventavano
Perciò i piemontesi
Hanno cambiato sistema
La seconda guerra
D'indipendenza
È combattuta
Da tre eserciti
Piemontese
Austriaco
Francese
Formati allo stesso modo
Con soldati
Non dico di mestiere
Perché sono sempre
Coscritti
Tirati a sorte
Ma che fanno
Il militare
A lungo
In Piemonte
Cinque anni
È l'esercito
Di caserma
In questo caso
Si vedrà
Che tutto sommato
Effettivamente
È meglio
Piuttosto che
Non richiamare
Una folla
Di riservisti
Che hanno dimenticato
Tutto
Ma l'esercito
Di caserma
Vuol dire
Che lo fai piccolo
Perché se tu
Ai coscritti
Dici
Dovete fare
Cinque anni
Di servizio militare
E quanti
Ne puoi prendere
Puoi prendere
Un giovanotto
Su cento
Il paese
Lo sopporta
Prendi
Un giovanotto
Su cinquanta
Il paese
Lo sopporta
Se cominci a dire
Prendi un giovanotto
Su dieci
E gli faccio fare
Cinque anni
Il militare
Il paese
Non lo sopporta più
Quindi il sistema
Presuppone
Che se ne tirano
A sorte
Pochi
Più sfortunato
Li tocca
L'esercito è piccolo
È più piccolo
Rispetto al 48
60.000 uomini
Giulani
Ha 120.000
Il doppio
Dunque il re
Vittorio
Non si sogna
Di fermare
Gli austriaci
Se ne sta giù
Giù
A sud
Del Po
Geografia della pianura padana
Gli austriaci vengono dal Ticino
Sono a nord del Po
Se gli venisse mai in testa di passarlo
Prima che lo passino tutti
Ce ne vuole
Quindi a sud del Po
Si sta più al sicuro
A sud del Po
I piemontesi hanno grandi fortezze
La cittadella di Alessandria
La cittadella di Casale
Lì è l'esercito
Col suo re
Che conta i giorni
Aspettando che arrivino i francesi
Giulani
Il 7 maggio
Ha perso altri due o tre giorni
Si rimette in cammino
Da Vercelli
Verso occidente
A nord
Arriva fino a Biella
A sud
Entra tra le risaie
Del Vercellese
A questo punto
I piemontesi
Prendono una decisione
Estrema
Allaghiamo il Vercellese
Voi sapete che il Vercellese
È terra di risaie
Quindi è pieno d'acqua
È pieno di canali
Che vengono regolamentati
Per allagare le risaie
Quanto basta
In quei primi di maggio
Del 59
Il governo di Cavour
Decide
Apriamo tutte le chiuse
Allaghiamo il Vercellese
Vuol dire distruggere tutti i raccolti
Allagare le cascine
Crepa e bestiame
Non importa
Lo facciamo
Cavour in Parlamento
Dove ovviamente i deputati
Vercellesi
Protestano a gran voce
Cavour in Parlamento
Dice
Vi ricordate quando Napoleone
Marciallo su Mosca
E i russi hanno bruciato Mosca
Questa è la stessa cosa
Se non l'avessimo fatto
A quest'ora
Gli austriaci
Sarebbero in questa sala
Dice Cavour
Nel Parlamento di Torino
Il Vercellese viene allagato
La cosa più buffa
È che questo incarico
Di gestire questo allagamento
Viene dato a un ingegnere
Che ha la gestione appunto
Della rete idrica
Del Vercellese
E che viene incaricato
Di fare questo diluvio universale
E che evidentemente
Era un predestinato
Perché si chiamava
L'ingegner Noè
Dunque nel Vercellese
Allagato
I soldati di Giulai
Affondano fino alle ginocchia
Non ci si muove più
Eppure a un certo punto
A Vienna
Arriva una notizia fenomenale
Giulai
Ha preso Torino
Tedeum
Nelle chiese di Vienna
Poi arriva la rettifica
Non letto male il telegramma
Ha preso
Trino
Vercellese
Che qualcuno ricorderà
Perché è uno dei posti
Dove si era fatta
La centrale nucleare
Ai tempi
Della nostra
Disgraziata politica nucleare
Giulai è arrivato
Fino a Trino
È arrivato fino a Biella
Poi il Vercellese
È allagato
C'è notizia
Che i treni
Dei francesi
Stanno arrivando
E Giulai si ferma
Il 10 maggio
I corpi francesi
Scesi da Davanti Susa
Sono arrivati in treno
Ad Alessandria
Il 12 maggio
Napoleone III
Sbarca a Genova
Due giorni dopo
In treno
Anche lui
È ad Alessandria
A questo punto
Ad Alessandria
È concentrata
Una forza
Più forte
Di quella austriaca
Il rapporto di forze
Si è
Invertito
E in guerra
Naturalmente
Quello che succede
Di solito
È che finché sei più forte
Sei tu che attacchi
Ma quando è più forte
L'altro
Tu ti fermi
E torni indietro
Adesso tocca
Ai piemontesi
E ai francesi
Attaccare
Giulai ripiega
Verso il Ticino
Non lo passa
Si ferma in Lomellina
Tra la Lomellina
Piacenza
Il Po
Per vedere un po'
Cosa succede
Ma insomma
Si è fermato
Napoleone III
E Vittorio
Devono decidere
Cosa fare
Capite
Comandare un esercito
In guerra
Vuol dire che
Continuamente
Devi decidere
Delle cose
O per quello
Che i generali
Leggono i capelli bianchi
In guerra
Perché tutti i giorni
Devi decidere qualcosa
E non sai mai
Se stai decidendo
La cosa giusta
Oppure una cosa
Per cui ti passerai
Alla storia
Come un imbecille
Che ha fatto
Una scelta catastrofica
Non lo sai mai
Prima
Discutono
Siamo ad Alessandria
Siamo a sud
Del Po
Magari restiamo
A sud del Po
Marciamo su Piacenza
E poi attacchiamo
La Lombardia
Da sud
Certo
Però bisognerà
Attraversare il Po
Da qualche parte
Si lavora di carte geografiche
Dove ci sono i ponti
Sul Po?
Stradella
Potremmo passare
Il Po a Stradella
Però capite
Cosa vuol dire
Con 180.000 uomini
Attraversare un fiume
Così
E se l'altro
Ti attacca
Mentre sei a metà strada
L'alternativa
Sarebbe che
Il Po
Passiamo tranquillamente
Nelle nostre retrovie
In treno
Ce ne andiamo tutti
A Vercelli
A Novara
E andiamo a picchiare
La testa nel piccino
Il buon vecchio sistema
Di una volta
Alla fine
Decidono di fare così
Di nuovo
Naturalmente
Il fatto è che
C'è il treno
Portare 180.000 uomini
Da Alessandria
A Vercelli
Col treno
In due giorni
L'hai fatto
A Vercelli
A Novara
E dunque
Decidono di far questo
Ma mentre
Non si sono ancora
Mossi
Giulai
Decide di far
Qualcosa a lui
Perché i giornali
Di Viena
Naturalmente
Continuano a tempestare
Cosa fa il generale
Conte Giulai
Perché non si muove
Faccia qualcosa
E un generale
In quei casi lì
Deve fare qualcosa
Cosa
Boh
Non è la minima idea
In questi casi
C'è una grande risorsa
Per i generali
Che non sanno
Cosa fare
Anche Carlo Alberto
Nel 48
L'aveva fatto spesso
Anche se io non vi ho raccontato
Tutti i dettagli
Si fa una cosa
Che si chiama
Una ricognizione
In forze
Vuol dire
Non andiamo
Con tutto l'esercito
Non ho per carità
Ma con una forza
Intermedia
Così se succede
Qualche guaio
Non abbiamo perso tutto
Andiamo un po'
A vedere
Se capita
Qualche occasione
Facciamo qualcosa
Giulai
Decide di fare
Una ricognizione
In forze
Verso Voghera
Per vedere
Se effettivamente
Il nemico
Ha deciso
Di venire su
Stando a sud
Del po'
Andiamo avanti
Finché non vai a vedere
Non lo sai
Non hai
Degli aerei
Niente
Devi andare a vedere
Giulai si muove
E va a vedere
Avanza lentamente
Con la solita fatica
Senza riuscire bene
A coordinare le mosse
Non è tanto in gambe
Giulai
Non è tanto esperto
Neanche lui
Questo ingresso nuovo
Degli austriaci
In territorio piemontese
E' anche il momento
In cui succedono
Le uniche atrocità
Della guerra
Perché nel Vogherese
I contadini
Sparano agli austriaci
E gli austriaci
Fucilano
C'è un caso
Di una famiglia
Di contadini
Otto persone
Maschi
Tutti fucilati
Dagli austriaci
Perché dalla cascina
Avevano sparato
Non sono frequenti
Queste atrocità
Nelle guerre dell'ottocento
Ogni tanto succedono
Dopodiché
Giulai viene avanti
Cercando di tastare il terreno
C'è il nemico
E si c'è
Anche i piemontesi
E i francesi
Mandano un giro
Della cavalleria
Per la cavalleria piemontese
Si accorge che gli austriaci
Stanno arrivando
Dove?
In quel paesino
Che si chiama
Dove lì?
Montebello
Lì c'è l'avanguardia austriaca
Attacchiamoli
Battaglia di Montebello
È la prima battaglia
Della seconda guerra
D'indipendenza
E si vede subito
Che qualcosa
È cambiato
Rispetto al 48
L'arrivo dei francesi
Ha cambiato qualcosa
Nel modo di fare la guerra
Ricordate nel 48
La maggior parte delle battaglie
Fanno pochissimi morti
50 morti a Pastrengo
40 morti a Goito
Perché nessuno va sotto
Nessuno va dentro
Nessuno ci crede davvero
Nessuno vuol correre rischi
Ma
Napoleone e i francesi
Invece sono disposti
A fare la guerra più sul serio
Montebello
È una piccola battaglia
Poche forze impegnate
Tuttavia
Gli alleati
Che impegnano 7600 uomini
Ne perdono 741
Il 10%
Degli uomini
Che hanno combattuto
Quel giorno
Rimangono morti
O feriti
O prigionieri
Gli austriaci perdono il doppio
È già una battaglia seria
Non a livello di quelle
Del vecchio Napoleone
Che in una battaglia
Ammazzava il 20%
Del suo esercito
Senza batter ciglio
Però
Il clima è già cambiato
Giulai
Ha trovato
Perché voleva trovare
Il nemico è lì
In forze
A Montebello
Viene respinto
Giulai
Torna indietro
E sempre meno
Capisce
Cosa deve fare
Perché tra l'altro
C'è un'altra novità
Che gli confonde
Le idee
Non solo
Il treno
E il vapore
Con cui i francesi
Sono arrivati
Così in fretta
Non solo
Il fatto
Che il nemico
È ad Alessandria
Ma ci potrebbe mettere
Due giorni
Per andare a Novara
E non vale
Una volta
Non si faceva così
La guerra
Adesso invece
Sì
Ma c'è anche
Un'altra cosa
Garibaldi
Perché nel 48
Quando Garibaldi
Era andato
Da Carlo Alberto
Offrendo la sua spada
Carlo Alberto
Aveva detto
Tutto meno
Che assumere
Questo comunista
Quindi
Via
Fuori dai piedi
Invece
Nel 59
Ci hanno ragionato
Un po' su
E hanno deciso
Che non si possono
Permettere
Di farne a meno
Il mondo
È proprio cambiato
Nel 59
Garibaldi
Non solo
L'hanno preso
Ma è generale
Dell'esercito
Piemontese
E i suoi volontari
Ricevono divise
E armi
Piemontesi
E sono una brigata
Dell'esercito
I cacciatori
Delle Alpi
C'è solo una cosa
Che non è cambiata
E cioè
Garibaldi
Vuol fare la guerra
A modo suo
Benissimo
Però
Un po' fuori dai piedi
Un po' lontano
Dall'esercito
Dove noi facciamo
Le cose serie
L'esercito è concentrato
A sud
Alessandria
Casale
A Garibaldi
Dicono
Tu vai a dar fastidio
Agli austriaci
Dall'altra parte
Varese
Como
Vai a vedere
Quei posti lì
Garibaldi
Prende la sua brigata
3.000 uomini
E con i cacciatori
Delle Alpi
Appunto
Fassa il vicino
E va a dar fastidio
Agli austriaci
Sono pochi
Però al comando
Di Giulai
Cominciano ad arrivare
Le notizie
Sconfitta
Varese
A Como
I Garibaldini
Sono entrati qua
Sono entrati là
Marciano nella zona
Dei laghi
Come se fossero
A casa loro
Giulai
Non sa che pesci
Prendere
E poi sapete
Noi lo sappiamo
Che le 5 giornate
Di Milano
Si sono fatte
Una volta
Nella storia
Le 48
E poi non si sono più fatte
Ma Giulai
Non lo sa
Mica
Giulai non lo sa
Se Milano
Non è di nuovo
Pronta
A insorgere
E come Milano
E tutte le altre città
Lombarde
Quindi è lì
Che non si muove
Paralizzato
Perché può succedere
Di qualunque cosa
I nostri
Attaccano
Si porta l'esercito
A Novara
Vercelli
Si passa
La Sessia
Passano per primi
Piemontesi
Con poche truppe
All'altezza di Vercelli
I francesi
Stanno arrivando
Giulai
Informato
Che i piemontesi
Sono passati
E che sono abbastanza pochi
Prova
Attaccarli
Ha fatto tutto
Quello che poteva
Poverete
Bisogna dire
Il primo paesino
Che si incontra
Passata la Sessia
Dopo Vercelli
E un altro nome
Di strade
Che si ritrova
In tutte le nostre città
Palestro
A Palestro
I piemontesi
Sono appena arrivati
Giulai
Attacca
Come al solito
Lentamente
Non tanto bene
I piemontesi
Per un po' resistono
Dietro però
Ci sono quelli
Che stanno fare la guerra
Sul serio
I francesi
Hanno i ponti mobili
Buttano i ponti
Sulla Sessia
Attraversano
Arrivano a Palestro
In giornata
Gli austriaci
Sono battuti
Respinti
Perdono il 15%
Delle forze impegnate
Le tariffe
Cominciano a salire
E Giulai
Cosa deve fare?
Dovunque
Ci ha provato
L'ha in respinto
Il nemico
È in massa
Oltre la sesia
A Novara
Ce la fa
Restare in Lomellina
Lomellina è subito sotto
Se questi vanno avanti
Rischiano di spuntarmi
Alle spalle
E Garibaldi
È a Bergamo
È a Brescia
È in Valtellina
Lo vedono dappertutto
Anche dove non c'è
Ma ormai c'è il panico
Giulai decide
Si torna dietro il Ticino
Basta correre i rischi
Questo esercito
Che faticosamente
È rimasto lì
In mezzo
Le risaglie allagate
Per qualche settimana
Adesso basta
Torna indietro
La sera del 3 giugno
Giulai
Ha 120.000 uomini
Dietro il Ticino
Stanchi
Affamati
Di pessimo un gore
Perché non hanno fatto
Altro che perdere
E ritirarsi
Però sono lì
Il grosso dell'esercito
È accampato
Intorno
A un altro nome di via
Però stavolta
Non soltanto
Un nome di via
Delle città italiane
Ma anche un nome di via
Di Parigi
Magenta
Il grosso di Giulai
È dietro il Ticino
A Magenta
I francesi
Passano il Ticino
Loro sanno fare la guerra
Non si accontentano
Dei ponti che ci sono
L'ho detto prima
Hanno i ponti di barche
E gettano i ponti
Dove vogliono
Dove non c'è il nemico
Ad aspettarli
Un altro nome di rue
Di Parigi
Rue de Turbigo
Turbigo
È Turbigo
Sul Ticino
Dove i francesi
Passano il fiume
Giulai
Per l'ennesima volta
E uno non può
Che avere simpatia
Per lui
Contrattacca
Quelli hanno passato
Il Ticino
Non sono ancora tutti
Anzi
Ci sono l'avanguardia
Francese
Se Giulai fosse Napoleone
Primo
Li spappolerebbe
Ma Giulai
Non è Napoleone
Contrattacca
Come al solito
Con poche forze
Con fatica
I francesi
Tengono
Dopo un po'
Passa in Ticino
Napoleone III
Che si guarda
Intorno
Un po' smarrito
Perché è la prima volta
In vita sua
Che combatta
Una vera battaglia
Non gli è mai successa
Questa cosa
Ed è impressionante
Perché non si capisce niente
Aveva dato degli ordini
Nessuno li ha eseguiti
Manda degli ordini
Nessuno trova i generali
Perché non si sa dove sono
I soldati però combattono
È la nebbia della guerra
Nessuno sa niente
E nessuno capisce niente
Si cerca
Con fatica
Napoleone passa la giornata
A cercare di tappare i buchi
E finalmente
Alla sera
La linea tiene
L'attacco di Giulai
È fallito un'altra volta
I francesi hanno vinto
La battaglia di Magenta
Lasciandoci più di 4.000 morti e feriti
Il 7%
Gli austriaci hanno perso
10.000 uomini
Il 16%
Delle truppe impegnate
E sono battuti
Il polone terzo
Passa quella notte
La notte dopo
La sua prima grande battaglia
Una grande vittoria
Gli dicono i suoi
Lui stesso non sa bene
Se crederci o no
Si era immaginato
Tutto un'altra cosa
Quando sentiva raccontare
Le battaglie dello zio
È stato lì tutto il tempo
In mezzo a questo macello
Cercando di fare qualcosa
Senza capire bene
Cosa succedeva
Alla fine è andata bene
Certo che la guerra
Non è appunto
Come lui se l'immaginava
E per di più
Tutti questi morti
Però intanto va bene
Va benone
Va benissimo
Giulai si ritira
Il 8 giugno
Napoleone e Vittorio
Entrano a Milano
Liberata
Giulai si è ritirato
Indietro
Dove?
Chi c'era ieri
Se lo ricorda
E anche gli altri
Se lo ricordo
Dove vanno gli austriaci?
Nel quadrilatero
Il lago di Gandaco
Peschiera
Verona
Mantua
L'Ignago
Lì
La Valdadige
Per comunicare
Con la madrepatria
Il Po a sud
Che ti protegge in fianco
Il lago a nord
Stai lì
Giulai si ritira
Dietro il Mincio
E gli altri
Devono decidere
Cosa fare
Tanto per cambiare
Finiti i festeggiamenti
A Milano
Qualcosa bisognerà fare
C'è un problema
Come c'è sempre
Nelle guerre
Combattute
Da eserciti
Alleati
Qui abbiamo due eserciti
Due sovrani
Un imperatore
E un re
Peccato che naturalmente
Non so
Suo stesso livello
Il re ha 60.000 uomini
L'imperatore
Ne ha 120.000
Inoltre
Il re
Crede di essere
Un grande
Eh no
Questo non è diverso
Sono uguali
Tutti e due
Vogliono essere
Dei grandi generali
La differenza
Forza è che Vittorio
Ci crede
Di essere un grande generale
Napoleone
Comincia a avere
Qualche dubbio
In cuor suo
Però non ci sono dubbi
Comunque
Chi deve comandare
È Napoleone
Sono i francesi
Che comandano
I generali piemontesi
Sono anche contenti
Perché hanno preso
Le misure di Vittorio
E tutto sommato
E invece Napoleone
Piace
Un'altra cosa
Andiamo a dirlo
Per me è troppo facile
Scherzare su Napoleone
In piccolo
Come disse Ritoigo
Perché fu battuto
Dai brussiani
Ma in quel 59
Napoleone
È al massimo
Dello splendore
Ci credono tutti
Che sia davvero
Il degno
Nipote
Di suo zio
In generale
Solaroli
Aiutante di campo
Di Vittorio
Emanuele II
Il nostro
Re
All'infuori
Del coraggio
E dell'avventatezza
Non ha nulla
Non ha occhio
Né sangue freddo
Non si ricorda mai
Il nome di un paese
Che per uno
Che deve fare la guerra
E mandare degli ordini
Evidentemente
Ecco
Chi sa far la guerra
È l'imperatore
Fortuna per noi
Che abbiamo alla testa
Un tale uomo
Voi potete immaginare
Come contento Vittorio
Di fare la guerra
Agli ordini
Di Napoleone III
Vittorio
Su Napoleone III
Chi è dopo tutto
Quest'uomo
Questo bischero
L'ultimo venuto
Dei sovrani
D'Europa
Un intruso
Tra di noi
Farebbe meglio
A ricordare
Chi è lui
E chi sono io
Il capo
Della prima
E più antica
Dinastia
Veniante
D'Europa
Il povero Vittorio
Non ha solo grane
Con l'imperatore
Ha grane anche
Con Cavour
Perché anche Cavour
Conosce il suo re
E sta a Torino
Perché è primo ministro
Non può andare al fronte
Però da Torino
Cavour tutte le notti
Sta sveglio pensando
Chissà che stupidaggine
Avrà fatto oggi
Speriamo in bene
E tutti i giorni
Scrive al re
Dandogli dei buoni consigli
Capite la faccia di Vittorio
Quando arriva la staffetta
Con la lettera di Cavour
Tanto che alla fine
Vittorio non ne può più
E scrive a Cavour
Mi dice
Che devo essere circondato
Da tanti geni
Che mi impediscano
Di fare delle bestialità
Pare che lei
Mi considera
Un grande asino
Nel mio mestiere
Se lei mi parla
Ancora una volta
Così
Vedrà cosa farò
Manderò via
Tutti d'intorno a me
Quelli che vi sono
E mi circonderò
Di meno capaci ancora
E farò vedere
Se io non so fare
Il mio mestiere
Senza tanti consiglieri
Qui capite
Fra l'altro
Fatemi fare questo inciso
La bellezza
Del mio mestiere
Noi leggiamo
Noi leggiamo queste lettere
Che dovevano leggere
Soltanto i destinatari
E noi invece le leggiamo
E
Dopodiché
Ultima citazione
Vittorio
Acavur
Siamo sottoposti
A nuove
Tribolazioni
Non è più lei
Che ci tormenta
È il
Demissimo
Imperante
Il quale
Ci comanda
Bacchetta
Cambia
E discambia
I suoi progetti
E vuole
Cose impossibili
Ora
In questo bel clima
Bisogna decidere
Una buona volta
Cosa fare
Gli austriaci
Ci sono dietro
Il mincio
Quello che non tutti
Sanno ancora
Il comando
Francese
Piemontese
È che in Austria
Si sono stufati
Del generale
Conte Giulai
E l'imperatore
Ha deciso
Di venire a prendere
Il comando
Personalmente
Perché anche di là
Sono l'imperatore
Ed è per noi
Italiani
Una vecchia conoscenza
È Francesco Giuseppe
Che sarà ancora
Sul trono
Al tempo
Della prima guerra mondiale
Morirà nel 1916
Ai tempi
Che stiamo raccontando
Nel 59
È già sul trono
Da 10 anni
Benché ne abbia
Solo 29
È un giorno 8
Non ha mai fatto
La guerra in vita sua
Nel 48 c'era
Però ha visto
Una battaglia anche
E poi è molto studiato
Si è molto interessato
Di strategia militare
È molto appassionato
Di cose militari
Dell'esercito
Sapete che
Nell'impero osburgico
L'esercito
È il vero pilastro
Di questa monarchia
Multinazionale
L'unica forza
Compatta unitaria
È l'esercito
Dunque Francesco Giuseppe
È il terzo sovrano
Che incontriamo stasera
Che non ha mai fatto
La guerra in vita sua
Ma che decide
Che lui forse
Potrebbe anche essere
Un grande generale
E quindi
Licenzia Giulai
E viene a Verona
A prendere il comando
Del suo esercito
Dall'altra parte
Francesi e piemontesi
Avanzano lentamente
Hanno passato l'olio
Ci si avvicina
Al mincio
Fra il Garda
E il Po
È una fetta di terra
Minima in realtà
Saranno 70 km
Non di più
Stretta quindi
Se uno rappresenta
Su una cartina
I movimenti degli eserciti
Occupano quasi
Tutta la zona
L'estrema sinistra
Sul Garda
L'estrema destra
Quasi al Po
Gli eserciti sono grossi
Non possono marciare
Un esercito di 200.000 uomini
Non può marciare tutto
Sulla stessa strada
Sarebbe lungo 50 km
La colonna
Bisogna usare strade parallele
Quindi gli eserciti
Sono dispersi
L'abilità sta poi
Nel sapere
Dove sono le tue truppe
E riunirle
Nel momento
In cui hai deciso
Che ti servono
E quella è la cosa
Che sapeva fare
Napoleone I
I cui soldati
Non per niente
Dicevano
L'imperatore
Vince le battaglie
Con le nostre gambe
Perché al momento buono
Arriva l'ordine
E tu in 24 ore
Devi essere lì
Napoleone III
E Vittorio
Non sono proprio
Lo stesso livello
Ma per fortuna
Neanche Francesco Giuseppe
È proprio lo stesso livello
Stanno venendo avanti
Su questo vasto fronte
Senza sapere
Cosa c'è davanti a loro
Come al solito
Perché non li hai visti
Quello che non sanno
È che Francesco Giuseppe
Ha deciso di contrattaccare
Francesco Giuseppe
Il 23 giugno
Passa in vicio
Con tutto l'esercito
E dunque
Gli sta venendo incontro
Anche lui
Disteso su un fronte
Troppo grosso
Anche lui
Senza sapere niente
Di cosa c'è davanti
Il giorno dopo
24 giugno
Si incontrano
Su questo fronte
Amplissimo
Che a nord
Vicino al Garda
È incentrato
Su una collinetta
Che si chiama
San Martino
E al centro
È incentrato
Su un paesino
Con un'altra collinetta
Che si chiama
Solferino
E poi si va giù
Ancora più giù
Altre truppe
Anche a sud
All'anno a sinire
Si incontrano
Si comincia a combattere
Ed è la grande
Gloriosa battaglia
Di Solferino
È l'altrettanto gloriosa
Secondo gli storici
Sabaudi
Battaglia di San Martino
Che come tutti sappiamo
Viene vinta
Quello che meno si sa
È la fatica enorme
Che viene fatta
Per vincere questa battaglia
Che è quella
Che i tecnici
Chiamano una battaglia
Di incontro
Cioè non c'è uno
Che attacca
E uno che si difende
Stavano andando
Tutti avanti
Alla cieca
E si sono picchiati
Dentro l'uno nell'altro
Ma si vede quasi subito
Che i francesi
E i piegointesi
Sono di più
Sono più numerosi
Quindi dopo un po'
Cominciano a premere
E gli austriaci
Devono difendersi
Su questo fronte
È troppo lungo
Per cui nessuno sa
Cosa succede
A 30 km di distanza
Noi lo sappiamo oggi
A nord
Vicino al Garda
Ci sono i piemontesi
E c'è questa collina
Di San Martino
Con trincerati gli austriaci
Al comando di un generale bravo
Il Beneve
I piemontesi arrivano
Come al solito
Un po' per volta
Perché stanno marciando
Non era prevista la battaglia
Vittorio è lì
Nel suo elemento
Ricordate come diceva
Nel suo lettere
Il mio mestiere
Finalmente Vittorio
Può comandare una battaglia
Cosa vuol dire
Comandare una battaglia
Sguailare la sciabola
E andare all'attacco
La prima brigata piemontese
Che arriva
Il re sguaila la sciabola
E la manda all'attacco
E viene respinta
La seconda che arriva
Il re sguaila la sciabola
E la manda all'attacco
E viene respinta
Però poi ne arriva una terza
E la prima
Si è un po' riposata
E la si rimanda dentro
E se ne manda dentro
Un'altra che è appena arrivata
E Vittorio è nel suo elemento
In mezzo ai suoi soldati
A cavallo
Con le palle che fischiano
Si diverte da pazzi
Si sente finalmente
Un vero generale
E la fanteria piemontese
Va dentro
Sale la collina
Gli altri sparano
Si ridiscende in disordine
E poi ci si ritrova
Vanno avanti così
Tutto il giorno
Dall'altra parte però
Il generale Benedek
Riceve continuamente
Lettere del suo imperatore
Che è a Solferino
E che gli dice
Venite giù ad aiutarci
Ma Benedek
Non può andare giù
Non può mollare la collina
Ai piemontesi
Altrimenti li prenderebbero sul fianco
Quindi questi incessanti attacchi
Dei piemontesi
A qualcosa servono
La destra l'Austria
Che è incastrata lì
Poi finalmente
La sera
Benedek
Sulla sua collina
Riceve l'ultima staffetta
Di Francesco Giuseppe
Che gli dice
Abbiamo perso la battaglia
Ci riferiamo
E gli austriaci
Sgombrano la collina
Di San Martino
E Vittorio ci sale
Con la sciapola sguainata
E si può mandare
Il telegramma a Torino
Abbiamo vinto
La grande battaglia
Di San Martino
Ma la battaglia
Veramente grande
È stata giù
A Solferino
Al centro
Dove ci sono i due imperatori
E dove Napoleone è terzo
Per la seconda volta
Si trova lì
A dire bene
Cosa avrebbe fatto
Lo zio
Lui è lì
Gli austriaci resistono
E i francesi vanno dentro
È un esercito bello
Coraggioso
Pieno di slancio
Quasi uguale
A quello del vecchio Napoleone
L'unica differenza
È che i francesi
Intanto hanno inventato
Una cosa
Che poi gli piace così tanto
Che se la portano dietro
Fino alla prima guerra mondiale
I pantaloni rossi
E i soldati francesi
Piacciono da morire
E raddoppiano il loro entusiasmo
E il loro slancio
Ovviamente è anche più facile colpirli
Quando sono in mezzo
Ma pazienza
Non importa niente
Si va dentro
A Solferino
I francesi attaccano
E gli austriaci si difendono
Sempre più faticosamente
E Napoleone è lì in mezzo
E alla fine si ricorda
Cosa avrebbe fatto lo zio
Lo zio aveva la guardia
La vecchia guardia di Napoleone
I granatieri
Con i colbacchi di pelo d'orso
All'ultimo momento
Li mandava dentro
E poi rispondavano tutto
E anche Napoleone III
Alla guardia
Ovviamente l'avrebbe fatto
Iguale, identica
Con i granatieri
Con i colbacchi di pelo d'orso
Tutto
Quando si ricorda questo
Dà ordine alla guardia
Di andare dentro
E la guardia sfonda
E la battaglia di Solferino
È vinta
Francesco Giuseppe
Si accorge
Che se non si ritira
Crolla tutto
E dà l'ordine di ritirata
Tra francesi e piemontesi
Hanno perso qualcosa
Come 15 o 17 mila uomini
Morti, feriti, prigionieri
Tra il 10 e il 15%
Gli austrieci hanno perso
20 mila uomini
Il 20%
Queste sì che cominciano
A essere cifre
Come nelle battaglie
Del vecchio Napoleone
Infatti succede una cosa
No, diverse cose naturalmente
Su questo campo di battaglia
Dove quindi ci sono
Decine di migliaia
Di morti e feriti
Migliaia di cavalli morti
Cavalli agonizzanti
Bisogna finire a pistolettate
In mezzo a questo caos
Succedono due cose
Che poi la storia si ricorda
Uno
C'è uno svizzero
Che non mi ricordo più
Cosa era via fare
Si chiama
Henri Dunant
Che vede
Quanto sono pochi i medici
Come sono insufficienti
I servizi
Di assistenza degli eserciti
E gli viene l'idea
Che bisognerebbe organizzare
Una grande istituzione internazionale
Per l'assistenza
Ai feriti
In guerra
La fonderà
E la chiamerà
La croce rossa
L'altra cosa
Che succede
E' che Napoleone III
Ha visto davvero
Cos'è una grande battaglia
E qui uno non sa
Se dire
No
Si è visto che alla fine
Non valeva quanto lo zio
O se in fondo
Pensare che da un punto di vista
Umano
Aveva le sue ragioni
Napoleone III
Decide che basta
Con questa battaglia
Questa guerra
Ne ha visti abbastanza
Ne ha visti abbastanza di morti
Adesso basta
Questa guerra
La chiudiamo qui
Poi naturalmente
Si può riflettere
Su tante altre cose
Napoleone III
Sa che la Prussia
Sul Reno
Si sta armando
Napoleone III
Sa che è una bella cosa
Indevolire l'Austria
Però anche a rafforzare
Troppo in Savoia
Non è detto
Che convenga
Alla Francia
Gli abbiamo già conquistato
La Lombardina
E il Veneto
Se lo conquistassero
Da soli un'altra volta
Va bene così
Appena Francesco Giuseppe
Propone un armistizio
Napoleone accetta
E pensare che
Stava andando avanti
Ha passato il Vincio
Si prepara
A sediare Peschiero
A Verona
Però appena
Si parla di armistizio
Meglio così
Lasciamo perdere
E pensare che
In Austria
C'era già il panico
Perché l'interatore
È stato sconfitto
In una grande battaglia
Chi li ferma più
I francesi
Vi cito questo
Piccolissimo aneddoto
Che io ho trovato curioso
In quei giorni
Esce su un giornale tedesco
Un articolo
Di un critico militare
Un giornalista
Specializzato
Nel seguire la guerra
Che in vita sua
Si è occupato anche
Di altre cose
Si chiama Engels
Friedrich Engels
E' quello che
Dieci anni prima
Ha pubblicato
Il manifesto
Del partito comunista
Insieme a Marx
Nel 59
Pubblica un articolo
Di critica
In questa guerra
In cui dice
Supponiamo che
Un esercito francese
O italiano
Voglia invadere
L'Austria
Dalla pianura padana
Che è quello
Che tutti a Viena
In questo momento
Temono
Cosa dovrebbe fare
Un esercito tedesco
Per impedire
Per impedire che
Che gli italiani
O i francesi
Dal friuli
Trabocchino
Verso l'Austria
C'è un punto
Preciso
Che la geografia
Di quelle zone
Ci indica
Come il più adatto
Per contrattaccare
Gli italiani
E batterli
Si chiama
Caporetto
Giuro che è vero
Engels
Ha scritto questo
Nel 1859
Il posto adatto
Per sconfiggere
Gli italiani
E Caporetto
Dopodiché
Non ce n'è bisogno
Perché Napoleone III
E Francesco Giuseppe
Si mettono d'accordo
11 luglio
Arrestizio di Villafalca
Vittorio Emanuele
Non è tanto contento
Ma che ci può fare
Firma
Quello che ci resta
Peggio di tutti
È Cavour
A Torino
Il quale aveva costruito
Tutto questo
Con l'idea
Che la facciamo finita
Facciamo l'unità
D'Italia
Magari se ci va bene
Abbattiamo
L'impero austriaco
C'era stato un momento
Durante i negoziati
Quando si parlava
Del famoso congresso
L'Inghilterra
Non voleva la guerra
E tutto
In cui Cavour
Aveva scritto
A un suo amico
Non ci sarà
Inghilterra
Che possa impedirci
Di andare
A bruciare
Viena
Noi metteremo
Il fuoco
All'Europa
E invece
11 luglio
A Villa Franca
Hanno firmato
L'armistizio
Ci danno
La Lombardia
Basta
Cavour
Si precipita
A Villa Franca
E ha un colloquio
Tempestosissimo
Con il Re Vittorio
Colloquio
Durante il quale
Sono solo loro due
In una stanza
Gli altri fuori
A prendere l'orecchio
Per sentire
Si sentono le grida
Poi il Re
Esce
Pallidissimo
E dice
Che Cavour
È impazzito
Che è un tiranno
Che lo ha chiamato
Traditore
Cavour
Al Re
Che si è dimesso
Da primo ministro
E che ha detto
Al Re
Che i ministri
Sanno quando è ora
Di dimettersi
Ma il Re
Devono sapere
Quando è ora
Di abdicare
Che non è una cosa
Carina da dire
Il figlio di Carlo Alberto
Che 11 anni prima
Aveva dovuto abdicare
Per l'appunto
Dopo la sconfitta
Di Novara
Cos'altro
Si Cavour
Dice
Il Re
Ha buttato
Per terra le secce
Talmente
Era furioso
Il Re
Vittorio
Trova che
Tutto sommato
Una cosa buona
In questo c'è
Cavour
Si è dimesso
Fuori dai piedi
A Napoleone
Terzo
Vittorio dice
Pagherei
Un milione
Di franchi
Purché se ne andassi
In America
Più andava possibile
Quindi
Cavour
A un amico
Scrive
Mi accorgo
Che per me
È cominciata
La ricchiaia
Anche qui
Vedete com'è bello
Noi lo sappiamo
Loro no
Noi sappiamo
Che dì a poco
C'è l'insurrezione
In Sicilia
Garibaldi
Torno
Le camice rosse
Quarto
Tutto per aria
Loro non lo sanno
Allora è sempre finito tutto
E noi abbiamo anche
Quasi finito
Praticamente finito
Perché la guerra
È finita lì
È stata cortissima
Avete due mesi di guerra
Tre battaglie
Però c'è una piccola appendice
Che volevo raccontarvi
Perché quando le guerre
Si vincono
Si scrivono le marce triunfali
Come la marcia di Gadeschi
Nel 48
Quando le guerre
Si perdono
Cominciano le inchie
E a Vienna
Pochi mesi dopo
Un'inchiesta
Rivela
Una gigantesca
Frode
Nel commissariato
Dell'esercito
Cioè nel dipartimento
Delle forniture alimentari
All'esercito
Ve lo dico
Perché è interessante
Vedere che così
Era davvero
Lì per lo steve
Noi oggi diciamo
Certe volte
La buona amministrazione
La frode
Consigliere di questo
Corrono voci
Ma non sono confermate
Che sia stato
Napoleone terzo
Che ha rivelato
Che ha rivelato questa cosa
A Francesco Giuseppe
Perché Napoleone terzo
Ha delle buone sfide
E quindi si dice
Che a Villa Franca
Napoleone terzo
Ha detto a Francesco Giuseppe
Vostra maestà
È circondata di traditori
Crede che Mantua
Abbia infornimenti
Per sei mesi
Non ne ha neanche
Per sei giorni
E perché questo?
Per una serie di motivi
Per esempio
Il commissariato
Dell'esercito austriaco
Comprava buoi
Per la guarnigione di Mantua
Comprava settemila buoi
E li pagava
Ne arrivavano mille
Entravano in città
Da una porta
La attraversavano
Uscirono dall'altra porta
Facevano il giro dietro
E poi rientravano
Dalla porta di prima
E quelli erano
Gli altri duemila buoi
Poi tremila
Poi quattromila
Ma non basta
Perché poi c'era
Un'impresa
Di Trieste
Che comprava
Le pelli dei buoi
Perché una volta
Macellato il bue
Per darlo a mangiare
Ai soldati
Il commissariato
Vende la pelle
L'impresa di Trieste
Comprava settemila pelli
Con una clausola
Che se l'esercito
Non era in grado
Di fornirle tutte
Doveva pagare una penale
E siccome loro
Sapevano perfettamente
Che le pelle
Non sono mille
Firmando il contratto
Sapevano già
Che avrebbero incassato
La penale
Per altre 6.000 pelli
Ovviamente
Dovrei pagare poi
La mazzetta
Nuova generale
La colonnella
E così via
E non basta
Subito dopo la battaglia
Di Solferino
Quando ormai
Lo stato maggiore
È già chiarissimo
Che si chiederà
Il commissariato
Dell'esercito austriaco
Firma
Enormi contratti
Di forniture
Con commercianti privati
Che dovranno quindi
Fornire
Le stiame
Pane
Vino
Enormi quantità
Anche lì
Con la clausola
Della penale
Se per caso
L'esercito
È costretto
A annullare
Il contratto
Penale
Salta fuori
Che in tutti questi casi
Militari corrotti
E imprenditori
Sapevano tutto
E erano d'accordo
Salta fuori
Perché il comandante
Di tutta la sussistenza
Dell'esercito imperiale
Generale
Einatel
Quando nascono
I primi sospetti
Viene arrestato
Per essere interrogato
E si impicca
In cella
Con gli alamari
Della sua giubba
Dopo aver lasciato
Un biglietto
Con una piena confessione
In conseguenza
Vengono arrestati
Diversi uomini
In affari
In Trieste
Banchieri
In Vienna
Militari
Si sparano
Un colpo in testa
A un certo punto
Corre voce
Che sia coinvolto
Addirittura
Il ministro delle finanze
Dell'impero
Barone von Volk
Gli storici oggi
Pensano
Che fosse una falsa
Diceria
Che il barone von Volk
Non fosse coinvolto
Ma
Il barone von Volk
Fa l'unica cosa
Che nell'ottocento
Poteva fare
Un ministro delle finanze
Quando correreva
A voce
Che fosse coinvolto
In qualche scandalo
Si sparano
Un colpo in testa
Grazie
Applausi